you you have a lot of catchphrases a lot
of races that you use that you've made
up and maybe you could help me with some
of them because I have to admit I you
know I'm pretty Street but I don't
understand them all
how about bless up
well bless up is my way to greet
everyone like bless up you know bless up
you know when when I when I pick up the
phone bless up if I see you bless up you
know I'm starting off the energy great
positive love because love is the key is
so important for me yeah what's fresh
cut fresh cut is basically what's going
on right now you're saying like you know
you know you see the beard you see the
lineout you see the face a fresh cut no
is it really be honest be honest Alan to
get that to go like that yeah yeah no
but the match I'm sure somebody had
asked yeah so is that a lot of work in
the morning I have no idea this is three
hours in the oven this is like this is
like making a French pastry it's things
like that things like that yeah it's
like this is like a table you can feel
bad
get in there yeah you know that is a
hairspray um endorsements no it's
mayonnaise it's mayonnaise and it's a
lot of paper mache and there's two
gerbils living in here they like that
yeah and what's clawful er um special
cloth alert special cloth alert is me is
you when I see jay-z that special cloth
alert you're saying when I Michael
Jackson that special cloth alert Michael
Jordan Obama special cloth to learn you
know that that's like cut from a clock
that is one of one it's special it's
special cloth I'm special cloth to learn
know yo I like how you worked your way
in there - I like that yes you know
you